in this video we're going to get a
little bit of practice setting up
systems of linear equations
based on a word problem we're not
actually going to end up solving it you
can do that if you like just for kicks
but really we're going to just focus on
setting it up
so here we're told lauren uses a blend
of dark roast beans and light roast
beans to make coffee at her cafe
she needs 80 kilograms of beans in total
for her next order
dark roast beans cost three dollars per
kilogram
light roast beans cost two dollars per
kilogram and she wants to spend 220
dollars total
let d be the number of kilograms of dark
roast beans she buys and l be the number
of kilograms of light roast beans she
buys
all right so based on this information
that we've been given see if you can
pause this video and set up a system of
equations it's going to have two
equations with two unknowns d and l that
in theory we could solve to figure out
the right number of kilograms of dark
roast beans and light roast beans that
karen should use so pause this video and
try to work that out
all right now let's do it together and
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
underline so let's see we know that d
is dark roast beans and l is the number
of kilograms of light roast beans and
then they tell us here they say she
needs 80 kilograms of beans in total
so what we could say is hey the number
of kilograms of dark roast beans plus
the number of kilograms of light roast
beans needs to be equal to 80 kilograms
so the number of kilograms of dark roast
beans
plus the number of kilograms of light
roast beans i'm having trouble saying
light roast beans
well this what i just underlined here it
says needs to be 80 kilograms in total
so that needs to be 80.
so this number of kilograms plus this
number of kilograms is going to be equal
to your total number of kilograms all
right so i have one equation with two
unknowns let's see if we can get another
one
so next they say
dark roast beans cost three dollars per
kilogram
light roast beans cost two dollars per
kilogram and she wants to spend 220
total
so what i just underlined in this
aquamarine color we can set up another
equation with and if you haven't already
set up your system of equations see if
you can now do that see if you can set
up the second equation pause the video
all right well the way to think about it
is we just have to have an expression
for how much does she spend on dark
roast beans how much does she spend on
light roast beans and then we need to
add those two together and that needs to
be equal to two hundred and twenty
dollars because that's how much she
wants to spend in total so how much does
she spend on dark roast beans
well it's going to be the number of
kilograms
of dark roast beans that she buys and it
says that it costs three dollars per
kilogram so we're going to multiply it
by three three dollars per kilogram
times the number of kilograms of dark
roast beans this is how much she spends
on dark rose beans
and so how much is she going to spend on
light roast beans
well she buys l kilograms of light roast
beans they told us that there and they
cost two dollars per kilogram so two
dollars per kilogram times the number of
kilograms this is how much she spends on
light roast beans so you add how much he
spends on dark roast to how much he
spends on light roast and so this is
going to be
220 dollars in total and there you have
it we have our two equations with two
unknowns and so now we could go and
solve it but you can do that outside of
this video but the whole point of this
video is to understand how to construct
these based on the constraints based on
the information that we see in this so
typically when you're trying to set
these up
there's often a sentence or two that
will focus on one equation so this first
one is saying hey the the kilograms
let's add those up for the total number
of kilograms and then there's another
sentence or two that will focus on in
this case some other equation in this
case it's the price so the price of the
dark plus the price of the light is
going to be equal to the total amount
she wants to spend